judge katanji brown jackson supreme
court confirmation hearing wraps up
later today tensions and emotions ran
high yesterday when jackson faced some
of the toughest questions yet from
republican senators senators rather who
did a lot of the talking
so you're not going to answer my
question no i've answered your question
in my answer you haven't answered my
question i'm sitting here asking you and
you're declining to answer good
good
absolutely good i hope you are to do
good allow her to finish please okay in
that chart kate judge you said that
before the these are the eight or nine
child porn cases i will say to correct
the record i'll just say to the judge
there's no point in responding he's
going to interrupt you
nicole killing is in the hearing room on
capitol hill nicole i watched a lot of
the hearings yesterday it was very
painful to watch
a lot yesterday afternoon what can you
tell us about the plan for the final day
well the plan today is that judge
jackson won't be in the hot seat as a
panel of experts testify after an
emotional and exhaustive hearing with
searing attacks on the first black woman
who is likely to be confirmed to the
supreme court
i love this country
because i love the law
supreme court nominee katanji brown
jackson welled up on her final day of
questioning the chairman refused to
allow a witness to answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want it
was punctuated by several contentious
exchanges beginning with south
carolina's lindsey graham who needled
the judge over everything from whether
she watched justice brett kavanaugh's
hearings he was ambushed how would you
feel if we did that to you to relentless
questioning over her sentencing record
in child exploitation cases
you think it is a bigger deterrent to
take somebody who's on a computer
looking at sexual images of children in
the most disgusting way is to supervise
their computer habits versus putting
them in jail no senator i didn't say
first that's exactly what you said to
see the badgering of this woman
as she's trying to testify
i thought was outrageous to people who
felt your line of questioning was
inappropriate you say what
that she would not answer my question it
was a refrain echoed by other committee
republicans relitigating the same claims
i'm sitting here asking you and you're
declining to answer i've explained
how
the guidelines work judges all over the
country are grappling with
how to apply this guideline do you have
other questions for me
yeah i do
i do senators on both sides of the aisle
tried to turn down the dial i'm going to
try and spread some aloha into this room
i think we should recognize that the
jackassery we often see around here
is partly because of people mugging for
short-term
camera opportunities but it was new
jersey's cory booker who delivered this
closing argument
and you did not get there
because of some left-wing agenda
you got here how every black woman in
america who's gotten anywhere
has done
you have earned this spot you are worthy
you are a great american
there were other notable issues raised
for instance judge jackson said she
would recuse herself from an upcoming
supreme court case involving her alma
mater harvard if she is confirmed the
committee is expected to vote on her
nomination april 4. nate
nicole thank you
i must say the words of senator cory
booker were powerful it was very
powerful it was so tough i thought
yesterday to watch regardless of how you
feel about her it felt so personal
watching her
being really attacked for something that
has nothing to do with the job that
she's going to do that's the thing that
got me lindsey graham many of these
people voted for her several times and
now all of a sudden the way she was
treated i thought was very difficult to
watch yeah i think the word attack is a
fitting word yeah yeah